this is my favorite story all because
this happens a lot in families where
people they don't especially got fur
come the South and people don't grow up
around the gay culture so they're kind
of thrown by and they don't know how to
like handle it at first and I just love
y'all so much for sharing this story
it's gonna inspire so many people but
were you always into makeup
I was actually always into makeup I
loved it I loved seeing my mom transform
in the morning I loved seeing her turn
to superwoman you know like I could see
the transformation in her she felt more
confident she loved it and I was like oh
my god mom like this is like amazing and
I loved it
Matt alright did you struggle with me
and ease interest at first I definitely
did growing up in a Latino household the
LGBT community discussions never
happened it was it was something new to
me so I had a real hard time
understanding it and accepting it cuz
you didn't grow up around knowing grew
up in a completely different world
exactly exactly so it was very rough so
like Ava Beauty acceptance is a big part
of your brand do you relate to this Oh
completely especially what you were
talking about like my mother is my
biggest beauty inspiration and those
memories of watching her like transform
there's a perfect word she used to work
at the Hollywood Chinese Theatre and she
back in the 80s I didn't go to work with
her and she had to wear like the
very the Chinese I don't know what the
problem that gown you know with the high
collar and the red and I would watch and
we'd be on the bus it would be like
super like not elegant except she would
be this like you know he can yeah this
thing and so that that inspired me and
continues to inspire me that image of my
mother being this goddess you know yeah
my daughter thinks I'm a goddess I will
not stop talking until you subscribe to
my youtube channel that's right and I
could talk a lot seriously not gonna
stop yep still here not going anywhere I
see you don't walk away from this